come on
Against All Odds these Palestinian
children Trek across the valley to get
to school
some were their mothers afraid of what
could happen next
their school was demolished on Sunday
when Israeli forces bulldozed it in the
early hours of the morning they left
nothing behind the playground desks and
books all destroyed
locals tried to stop them but many ended
up in hospital
Celine was five when the European Union
funded school was demolished the first
time in 2017. this time she was at home
she says when she found out
I heard the sound of the night and asked
my mum what was happening she said my
school had been demolished and I had to
see it for myself and saw the Israeli
military had removed all the bricks I
was sad I loved school because I want to
be successful
the school is part of area C in the
occupied West Bank which is fully
controlled by Israel in the past Israel
has accused it of not having a building
permit almost all Palestinian permit
requests in this area are rejected
my grandfather who owns the entire area
at which the family decided to have a
school and they donated the land to the
school because we have no school in the
village
in a statement the EU said it was
appalled and that Israel's demolitions
of Palestinian homes and schools is
against international law in March an
Israeli courts granted a request from a
pro settler organization to have the
building demolished for safety reasons
if they care about the student
so why they didn't give us admission to
to build the
normal school
nearly 60 students attend the school
temporary tent is unlikely to last and
there is no running water or even
toilets
the last few days have been incredibly
tough for the kids here so they brought
in the Palestinian Circus school to
teach them some juggling as well as
these flower sticks that teaches them
balance now the teachers say not only
has their education been disrupted but
they've also been massively affected
psychologically so this just brings a
little bit of fun to their day
but Celine says none of this will stop
her from achieving her dreams
she loves numbers and wants to become a
math teacher when she grows up
in occupied West Bank
a war plane at a helicopter